"Bans off our body" :ps."
200 manifestations
dans cinquante États américains.
Le mot d'ordre a été entendu
partout à travers le pays.exas..
À Chicago...
San Francisco...
New York...
Atlanta...
les groupes pour le droit
à l'avortement sont mobilisés
depuis que la fuite
d'un document de la Cour suprême
publié sur le site d'informaquee
l'institution judiciaire
accorderait le droit aux États
d'autoriser ou d'irtement.
"Nous n'irons pas en arrière",
à Washington.
"C'est un retour en arrière
de la génération millénaire,et s
en arrière. C'est
la génération de mneuf mois
et je veux qu'elle puisse
décider pour son avenir."
Marilyn Bennet, quant à elle,
a une impression d
Elle luttait, dans les années
70, pour l'accès à l'avortement.
ans, dit-elle, je viens
du Texas, et nous étions venus
en autobus à Washington
dans les années 70, je doute
que les un jour de l'égalité."
Pour les manifestants ici,
ce n'est pas seulement l'accès
mais la santé des femme,
car, si vortement
demeure illégal aux États-Unis,
elles vont continuer à se faire,
et là, c'est leur santé
en jeu.
L'administration Biden
sur la question de l'avortement.
La Chambre des représentants
a voté, à l'automne dernier,
une loi garantissant l'accès
le pays, mais ce texte est
toujours bloqué au
51 sénateurs s'y sont opposés,
et 49 démocrates, l'ont appuyé.
que la question de l'avortement
sera l'enjeu principal
en novembre prochain.La décisior
suprême est prévue
à la fin du mois
au début du mois de juillet.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Gi